♪ Four and three
and two and one one
- Madonna, Rihanna, Ilana.
Yes, yes, yes.
I'm a female and I
love to inspect bodies.
All I gotta say,
is nuttin' but net.
- Oh!
- And, by nuttin'
but net, I mean,
he fingered me til I (beep)
- Wow!
- I'm gonna inspect
your dick, later.
Feels good.
We look, exactly, alike.
- Yeah, no (beep).
- Is there a pocket on the back?
- There is.
Also, has a leash hole.
- Not the first time
this has happened to me.
You're caramels, you're
queers, you're L's,
you're G's, you're B's,
you're T's, you're Q's.
- Thank you.
- No mo, fo mo.
- You just pulled a bag
of pot out of your vagina.
- Suck it up.
That's it.
Wheat grain.
(loud slap)
- Ow!
- You are my best friend!
Don't you ever call
anybody else that!
So, this is because
we're, clearly, lesbians.
- I'm gay.
- Let's get married.
- What was that?
- Love ya bitch.
This is really nice.
(car honks horn)
Ahhh, (beep) you!
- (beep) you!
(upbeat music)